well CNN is a dying pathetic husk of a
fake news organization but at least it
still serves a purpose and that purpose
is making the rest of us feel smart by
comparison and if it filled that
vocation again this weekend with an
op-ed on its website from one of its
senior writers quote unquote named John
Blake the headline what is digital
blackface and why is it wrong when white
people use it yes digital blackface and
no he's not referencing Justin Trudeau's
Twitter account the digital blackface
Scourge according to Blake is much more
widespread that he explains quote maybe
you shared that viral video of Kimberly
Sweet Brown Wilkins telling a reporter
after narrowly escaping an apartment
fire ain't nobody got time for that
perhaps you posted a meme of supermodel
Tyra Banks exploding in anger on
America's Next Top Model I was rooting
for you we were all rooting for you is
what the name says or maybe you uh
you've simply posted popular gifts such
as and it is GIF a gif such as the one
of NBA great Michael Jordan crying or of
drag queen RuPaul declaring girl if
you're black and you've shared such
images online you get a pass but if
you're white you may have inadvertently
perpetuated one of the most Insidious
forms of contemporary racism you may be
wearing digital blackface
now before we go any further I want you
to think about what Blake has just
unwittingly conceded here he has
essentially admitted that anti-black
racism is a non-issue in modern America
he admitted
all of that by by claiming that white
people posting Gifts of Tyra Banks are
engaging in one of the most Insidious
forms of contemporary racism now
whatever else we can say about these
gifts if they constitute one of the most
Insidious most Sinister most evil kinds
of anti-black racism in modern America
then that would mean that anti-black
racism is basically over
I mean certainly if we lived in a
culture where black people suffered
actual widespread systemic racism then
memes of Michael Jordan would not make
the top 10 list there were no gifts in
1850 during the slavery era but if there
were
nobody would have said that they
constitute one of the most Insidious
forms of racism at that time
if they do now then that should tell us
something
of course digital blackface is not a
thing and gifts are not racist but my
point is that we could actually concede
everything this ridiculous hack is
claiming we could Grant him the entire
premise
and it would only undermine his
underlying premise which is that
anti-black racism is a serious systemic
problem in modern America
in other words if he's wrong about this
subject he's full of crap but if he's
right about this subject he's still full
of crap either way this is one crap
filled man let's continue digital
blackface is a practice where white
people co-opt online expressions of
black imagery slang catchphrases or
culture to convey comic relief or
express emotions these Expressions what
one commentator calls racialized
reactions are Mainstays and Twitter
feeds Tick Tock videos and Instagram
reels and are among the most popular
internet memes digital blackface
involves white people play acting and
being black says Lauren Michelle Jackson
an author and cultural critic in an
essay for Teen Vogue Jackson says the
internet thrives on white people
laughing at exaggerated displays of
Blackness reflecting a tendency among
some to see black people as walking
hyperbole
another quick aside here we're all busy
people we have a lot going on well John
Blake doesn't he you know he has to he
has time to write a five thousand word
dissertation about memes that hurt his
feelings but some of us are busy which
means we look for shortcuts you know we
look for ways to assess and understand
things very quickly and here's one if
you're ever reading anything
that mentions an essay in Teen Vogue and
it's not in the context of making fun of
the essay but rather it's citing the
essay as an intellectual and moral
Authority then you can immediately
disregard everything else the author has
to say on that subject or any other
subject
and if you are ever writing something
and you find yourself
favorably citing an essay in Teen Vogue
then you can know that you have at some
point in the past suffered some kind of
head trauma that maybe you don't
remember and you need to seek medical
attention right away
more from CNN's John Blake
quote if you're still not sure how to
define digital blackface Jackson offers
a guide she says it includes displays of
emotions stereotyped as excessive so
happy so sassy so ghetto so loud our
dial is on 10 all the time rarely are
black characters afforded subtle traits
or feelings many white people choose
images of black people when it comes to
expressing exaggerated emotion on social
media a burden that black people didn't
ask for she says we are your SAS your
nonchalance your Fury your Delight your
annoyance your happy dance your Diva
your shade your yes moments Jackson
writes the weight of reaction giving
period rests on our shoulders
well if you were hoping that there would
be some kind of um rock bottom to our
cultural descent into stupidity now you
know better because if there was a rock
bottom then the paragraph I just read
would have to be it a paragraph which
ends with the sentence the weight of
reaction giving rests on our shoulders
this woman is pretending to be somehow
emotionally burdened by Gifts of black
people according to her she walks around
every day carrying the cross of gifts
she is a Christ figure suffering and
sacrificing herself so that the rest of
us can have memes
this is how she presents herself and yet
this is not our intellectual Rock Bottom
we are still falling still plunging
eternally into the idiot Abyss
now you've probably heard enough of this
article uh you've heard enough after the
after the title really but here's a bit
more quote
some may say posting a video of Sweet
Brown saying oh Lord Jesus it's a fire
it's just for laughs why overthink it
why give people yet another excuse for
labeling white people races for the most
innocuous behaviors
but critics say that digital blackface
is wrong because it's a modern day
repackaging of minstrel shows a racist
form of entertainment popular in the
19th century that's when white actors
faces darkened with burnt cork
entertained audiences by playing Black
characters as bumbling happy-go-lucky
simpletons that practice continued to
the 20th century on hit radio shows such
as Amos and Andy put simply digital
blackface is 21st century Minstrel C
so without a hint of irony the article
repeatedly uses a RuPaul meme as an
example of this 21st century minstrelcy
but not because drag is the modern day
Minstrel show which of course it is okay
these are the menstrual performers of
modern America uh so we do have
menstrual performers in this country but
they're they're wearing Woman face
rather than blackface
just as degrading just as dehumanizing
just as offensive just as insulting
that's not what the author means to him
RuPaul's is an example of modern day
Minstrel
only when a white person on Twitter uses
his image as a reaction gif
One Last Time back to the article says
historical blackface has never truly
ended and Americans have yet to actively
confront their racist past to this day
Aaron Wong writes in an academic paper
on the topic in fact Minstrel blackface
has emerged into even more subtle forms
of racism that are now glorified all
over the Internet Wong says that digital
blackface is wrong because it culturally
appropriates the language and
expressions of black people for
entertainment while dismissing the
severity of everyday instances of racism
black people encounter such as police
brutality job discrimination and
educational inequity
an academic paper on the topic we're
told this is the kind of thing they
write academic papers about
the fact that academic papers are
covering the same subjects as essays and
Teen Vogue should tell you everything
you need to know about Academia
and of course they're all just following
tick tock's lead indeed Tick Tock has
been on the front lines fighting against
digital blackface for years now
um here's one example
hi Benji here and I'm going to explain
what digital blackface is digital
blackface is where non-black people use
images or emojis of black people to
express emotion online often extreme
ones like anger or disbelief sometimes
images are edited to indicate Blackness
for this purpose the intents may be
innocent but digital blackface like the
original use of blackface exploits
Blackness through media for
entertainment that overuse of these
images also reinforces negative
stereotypes that drive racial
discrimination we can use images of
people that are A different race it's
okay to enjoy popular culture we should
just be conscious of the impacts the
meter that we share online may have on
communities with less privilege for
example if you find you always use
images of black women to express SAS
consider the negative stereotypes you're
reinforcing and how the smart reflects
your own unconscious biases and try a
different image next time hope that
helps bye
you know I would really prefer if they
just yelled at us like they obviously
want to because this cheerful smiling
routine is is it's just intolerable
tolerable I mean there's something even
more repugnant about this kind of tone
hey guys hope you're having a great day
hey by the way you're racist if you do
this totally normal and innocuous thing
do as I say you white Devils okay bye
bigots love you
that's even worse and of course the
condescension is part and parcel here
patronizing smugly disdainful none of
that is incidental leftism is after all
an ideology of trifling tyrants
constantly looking for new ways to
manipulate us the pettiness is the point
I mean these are people who invented the
word problematize which literally means
taking something that is not a problem
and turning it into a problem
they aren't trying to solve problems
they're trying to create them and they
aren't even hiding it they'll admit it
that's why this kind of garbage this
push to make every benign thing into a
racist assault on black Identity or into
some other form of bigotry even now
including memes may seem idiotic and
laughable and it is I mean it is idiotic
and we should laugh at it absolutely but
underneath the stupidity bubbling just
under the surface is the very real and
very Sinister agenda to control every
last aspect of our lives and of our
expression and of our words and uh our
thoughts
you know they they uh they don't want
you to do say or think anything without
referring to them first to see if it's
allowed that's why the the pettier the
better the more seemingly innocuous the
better because they want you to start
thinking that oh man like this this the
thing I thought didn't matter at all is
like I can't even do this without being
a racist
that's the agenda
but whether we engage with this on the
surface level or we consider what lies
underneath it
our response should be the same
and the response again should be utter
content
disdain
dismissiveness and mockery
that should be our response to them that
is by far and away
the only acceptable answer at this point
and a necessary answer that'll do it for
this portion of shows and move over to
members block hope to see you there you
can become a member and use coded wall
should check out for two months free on
all annual plans uh and if we don't see
you there talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]